you're struggling a lot weren't you
concerts are getting those I think we
put so much pressure on ourselves can't
even get like Finance for a microwave
and that was the beans on Tuesday yeah
and then you came across yay and then
he's like oh we don't actually need
money and you've built up now a nice
portfolio how much a year is it bringing
in about 350. 350 Grand a year how did
you feel when you saw the money coming
in from that first property is it real
you then went on to get your second deal
and then your third your fourth you've
now got two huge lease option agreements
which is basically like Buy It Now with
an agreement where you're allowed to pay
for it later the fact that you did it
with bad credit and no money yeah and
now you know you're making six figures
it's absolutely remarkable what's the
difference between what you're doing now
and what you were doing eight months ago
when you were just getting completely
rejected what changed definitely mindset
because at the beginning we was the
adventurement's not going to work we
can't find any because we kept getting
the nose like a downward spiral and but
we kept fighting got the s
well firstly congrats on all your
massive success making six figures a
year now yeah started with very little
why don't you talk about the beginning
how did you get started in property and
how did it all come about yeah you
wanted to go on property didn't you but
we always thought we had to have money
yeah you asked your mum at first didn't
you just be like can we borrow some
money or try and like get her to buy the
property for us and then you came across
yay and then you say oh we don't
actually need money so we went to one of
your crash courses and then the first
crash course I went to I said do you
want to get a loan did you not have any
money at that point no no so it was just
you're not impulsive are you no um and
it was you the kind of went let's just
do it and that was the beans on toast
days that was yeah so obviously put
ourself in a worse state to do it but we
knew then it had to work right you don't
have a choice we've got to make this
work tried it from the videos as well so
YouTube kind of went out tried it and
then I realized I was like no
no we need to
actually get some education on it and
try and do it so what was your very
first property deal then what was the
when was the first time you got the keys
to a property
um April May time was the first and that
was a HMO
um has a HMO license we've done it as
essay through the summer just because
the students there obviously that time
then it doesn't work and you've built up
now a nice portfolio that's bringing in
how much how much a year is it bringing
in about 350. 350 Grand a year yeah
incredible and what kind of profit is
that making
140 Grand a year and then we take out
70. as a salary right yeah and and
you've now you've quit your jobs what
you were doing previously you've got
your last day I think next week on
Friday yeah which is how does it feel
because I know you're working like
really hard as well yes so I don't get
to see my family my kids and everything
so it's so nice to feel that freedom is
just nearly there when's your last day
Friday and what were you doing before
Liam so we had like reselling eBay
business that type of thing but again
that was more like a job so use time to
take photos and go and Source the
products and we still wouldn't see each
other so it was in the house but I was
in the office it's like what yeah
sometimes it's easy to think yeah you
have a business but really you kind of
own a job yeah which which is which is
which is crazy so your first property
was a HMO what is your what did your um
work say when you told them that you
were doing property Lauren and you were
like leaving
they was like playing jokes like oh look
at the millionaire over there and you
can buy us cars when you get there and
stuff they was like supportive but
didn't quite believe me talked about how
you structured that first deal the first
HMO that you got you had no money yeah
you got a loan out and you did some
mentoring and training with me through
the academy
um how did you structure the first deal
how did you find it how did you
structure it how did you make it stack
how does it make profit so we found it
through an agent
um just phoning up conster getting those
and then we kind of changed the strategy
to what you taught and I just went
like do you know the system like rent to
rent and all that type of thing and we
clicked from someone he's done it but
now he has a letting agency we can just
text him now and he'll say yeah I've got
this or not yeah
um money side of it we joined ventured
with someone else from the academy they
put the funds in we do all the legwork
say uh and then right day to day where
is it it's in Plymouth so this is a big
house yeah and you're renting it from
the landlord the money that was used to
do like a little like refurb and just
The Upfront rent you got from a joint
venture partner on the academy and then
you rent it out on a room by room basis
what's the market like in Plymouth and
what do you do if you can't rent the
rooms out is there
we to be fair you don't we've got to
wait in this stuff don't have that
problem the demand is so crazy
like there's a we've got people lined up
ready for when people move out the
market at the moment as well generally I
mean I'm trying to get a house for my
sister at the moment which wants to move
down to this area and there's quite a
lot of houses available but when I ring
they'll be like oh we've had 14
applications for that oh yeah it's just
crazy so when people say to me what do
you do if you buy a house or if you if
you take on a rent to rent and you can't
rent it out I'm thinking well the
Market's crazy as long as you do your
due diligence properly and as long as
you advertise it in the right way at the
right price it's very unlikely you're
going to have that problem so we also
try to work it because where we are it's
really seasonal especially with like
service accommodation right
um so we make sure it works as a single
lap in the winter just so we can't just
go like look and put someone in there
putting the six month ASP throughout the
winter if you need to yeah so it's just
a backup so that it doesn't go wrong how
did you feel because especially Lauren
had been very skeptical at the beginning
how did you feel when you saw the money
coming in from that first property it
was like real like yeah it was mad it
was it's a really nice feeling you then
went on to get your second deal and then
your third your fourth you've now got
two huge lease option agreements yeah
talk to me about what a lease option
agreement is and then I want to talk to
you about how you managed to to build
your portfolio using these options yeah
so we've structured it so similar to the
rent rent but all you've got on the back
end of that you've got the option to buy
it not the obligation so we've got one
that has agreed at 750 000
um and you can patch it that for that
price let's say five years down the line
so what have you got how long have you
got to buy it five years on both okay so
one of them is a house what
is it they're both blocks of flats um so
one's got six Flats in and the other's
got five and a shop oh my goodness okay
so you've got two blocks of flats you've
secured them on a lease option agreement
which is basically like Buy It Now with
an agreement where you're allowed to pay
for it later yeah and is it making
profit as well yes how much profit do
they make so each one is about between
40 and 60k
each over the year that's just mad
Ness it's surreal yes it's mad what's
the difference between what you're doing
now and what you were doing
eight months ago when you were just
getting completely rejected what changed
mindset would be the big one definitely
a mindset because at the beginning we
was the adventurement's not going to
work we can't find any because we kept
getting the nose and but we kept
fighting got the S and then since the
first yes it's just we can do it and
then you think you first deal because I
always say this your first deal is your
hardest for sure yeah it is for sure how
long did it take you to get your first
deal from really going for it probably
about six months on it because you were
really struggling you were you got even
on even while you're on the academy yeah
you know you were struggling a lot
weren't you yeah and I think it's and I
don't mind talking about that at all I
think it's good to talk about it because
it's good for people to see the
hardships yeah
um you know talk to me about that
struggle I think we put so much pressure
on ourselves putting us ourselves in so
much debt we were just like it's not
working it's not we're not getting
anywhere what are we gonna do and
because we was our mindset was it's not
working nothing was working interesting
like a downward spiral and then I think
we was on about it on the way up here we
were trying to do deal sourcing
but it was taking up so much time and
you're starting with no money so then
you've got the fuel cost and you're
running around and so it's just you put
in again you're putting all that
pressure on you yeah and then we kind of
like change the strategy and concentrate
on that and then I can't remember
whether you were joking but what did you
say at the acpb about I yeah the
finances which you have a toaster yeah
like the credit was that bad is we can't
even get like Finance for a microwave oh
that was nice yeah
So you you're living on nothing yeah
you're working as a waitress you've gone
full-time property but it's not working
yeah yeah and then you didn't have
enough money for a microwave you tried
to get finer you could we could we could
buy it but like Finance wise because the
credit was so short that you just
wouldn't get how did your credit get so
bad I back along like I've done like
payday loans and yeah just stupid
decisions credit cards but didn't use
credit cards properly yeah and it'd just
be put on a bill but then you have to
pay that bill back then you couldn't
keep up with that and yeah just down
with spiral relay yeah and I guess the
fact that you did it with with bad
credit and no money yeah and now your
turn you know you're making six figures
it's it's absolutely remarkable what
does an average day look like for you
now like what are you what are you doing
on the business realistic it's not that
much is it no in the last couple days
we've actually systemized it quite well
so I don't need to go and clean every
day and yeah we spoke about this at the
ACP yeah yeah it was we was running
about quite a bit when we was like going
down us say there's a leak go down sort
it but now we've got people in places
that's great so now we've got time to
even just in the house just tidy up and
chill chill and just do normal
family stuff yeah which is really nice
so what do you prefer do you prefer
lease options or rent to rent I look at
them quite similar really because um
yeah you've got the option to buy it
but you've kind of got to keep that
money there so there's not as much cash
flow yeah obviously to build wealth is
good because one of the all these
options is like 1.2 million isn't it
yeah so one point one's 1.7 should be
worth 2.1 by the end of it yeah
um and then one 750. what happens if you
don't have the money
by the time the five year comes up it's
such a good property with profit if we
don't have the money we're about to find
the money from an investor but yeah if
not you don't have if you can't buy it
then you don't have the you you're not
obligated to buy anything what happens
if you agree to buy that for 1.7 million
and then after five years the Market's
taking them with all the stamp Duty
changes and stuff if the market just
shoots up and it's worth like two and a
half million and then the owner wants to
renegotiate the price it was in the
contract obviously we do have if it goes
up like let's say it goes up 50 we can
we'll put like an extra 10 on or
something like that
yeah so that's in the one on the ones in
Truro and the other one is just 750
um and that's right straight so even if
it's worth 1.5 million
you've got a restriction order on the
property you have the right to buy it
yeah as long as you exercise that option
within the next five years yeah that's
amazing so you've got your capital
appreciation and you've got your cash
flow yeah
um how's life changed then in the last
sort of six 12 months to be fair it
hasn't like that as in we've just been
concentrating on building it so we're
not really haven't really took much out
but we could yeah but it's just like
just scale it and then it's just going
to be like you know what let's just
start taking six grand out but then it's
been enough for you to leave your work
yeah yeah yeah so it's like is that but
you're not what you're saying is you're
not living luxuries you're not buying
fancy cars yeah we're still we're still
shopping in Primark and I think yeah
you know it's not about it's not about
what you spend it's about what you make
really yeah what would you say then if
you were advising somebody that was in
your situation that was maybe no money
bad credit really skeptical but was
thinking man it's a dream I'd love to be
able to do this knowing what you know
now what advice would you give I would
just say if you really really want to do
it you'd take that leap yeah if you have
the passion for it go for it like if the
only reason you're gonna fail is because
you're not put into practice what you've
learned yeah yeah you've got to have the
drive as well you've got to have a drive
to want to do it yeah because then when
it gets hard you just quit yeah you know
if you haven't got a strong reason why
and we talk about this we talk about
it's really important to have willpower
but willpower comes and goes sometimes
you feel like it sometimes you don't so
what you really need is you need y power
and if you have a strong read season
than when people say no when you're
getting rejected when you think your man
I've been working for you know a whole
month and I've not actually made any
money yet in the early days you've got
that reason that keeps you going what
was that why what was that driving force
that was keeping you going in the hard
times we've always wanted to have wealth
to be able to just go out and buy what
we want or the kids like take on holiday
and just simple simple things like going
to the shop and saying yes you can have
that just that little bit of freedom of
just not struggling yeah that is
probably my strongest why it's just to
live happily like easily with money yeah
mine's pretty similar obviously the kids
which I think anyone if they've got kids
that's the reason and then like
generational wealth so there's something
there for them really and what's your
like Vision then now you're about to
leave your job you're now full-time in
property you've got your cleaners and
your management your systemizing stuff
what's the next step for you guys
business wise I want a hundred in the
next four years 100 what rent rent or
rent to rent properties yeah so wow way
I'm looking at doing that is just
concentrating on Flats blocks of flats
yeah and scale it that way yeah because
there's two deals that you got where
they're the same owner yeah so one yes
one deal was how many flats
and a shot 11 and a shot lots of shop
so that's 12 properties including the
shop just from one person saying yes you
only got to do that eight or nine times
and then you've got 100 units I think
that's just you can go and keep ringing
up get one from one landlord like and do
it like that but it's gonna take so long
yeah it's just I don't think it's worth
doing it that way if you can get in what
are your areas that you're working in so
we've got hmos in Plymouth and then
cornwall's quite small yeah so our
service accommodation is Truro and new
key so we're gonna aim for that area
yeah yeah and what's how does it work
with service accommodation
um because I know that you've got quite
a few service combination properties how
does Cornwall work for instance like
what's Nuki like so nucleus just Gone
live on our Apartments it's been a
little bit slow but I think that was due
to our channel manager yeah but um we've
lowered the prices and it's broken out
quite nicely so we were thinking about
doing short like term lets through the
winter
but at the minute
I don't think we need to we're live
properly do they decided it's done with
that yeah where's the best area out of
all the areas that you've got for
service accommodation we've been full at
full all since we've opened so last was
it two months now really yeah it's been
pretty much full what sort of occupancy
are you talking then I would say you're
about 90 in you for sure eh and then
nuki's hard to judge because it's
literally
what the last week that has actually
been properly live yeah I would say
what's over the year true about 70 I
would say yeah because you've got you
can count like for winter and what are
you doing with your hmos how are you
finding the tenants and how are you
vetting them bear room and then open
referencing that type of thing okay so
you're what you're just taking pictures
putting it on spare room and then when
people are coming forward you're just
referencing them via software on open
rent and and making sure they can afford
it they've got their references have you
ever had any has there been any horror
stories like any tenants that are really
bad not paying rent yeah not yet
um rent's always been there we've got
one house where is
just that Goods gold got contractors in
there and then one worker yeah
um the others are like they're
professionals but younger professionals
but no issues you must you must be like
really proud of yourself yeah it's it's
surreal in it you gotta pinch yourself
sometimes just how far we come what are
your family and friends think of what
you've done they're supportive but
they're very like still don't really
know what it is
a little bit but yeah they are they are
supportive but now you've got like all
these Keys yeah Mr and Mrs landlords
with all these Keys everywhere with
property not just properties that you're
controlling but lease options where
you've literally got the option to buy
it yeah you benefit from the capital
appreciation I mean that's just
incredible and making the kind of money
that you're making you've quickly be
able to quit your jobs and I mean it's
it really is remarkable so some people
still a little bit unsure but no they I
think like for my mom she knows what
we're doing yeah like and she's fine but
she just doesn't understand the process
of it but
she just doesn't understand it how did
you deal with that initially with having
friends and family just totally either
not getting it or not supporting it or
we just got on with it don't really keep
the business separate
um there's a few that we can speak to
but yeah they don't understand it just
kind of keep it yes my mum lives in
France and I called her the other day
and said to her about the lease options
and she was like speechless and she's
like really happy so it's just really
nice to have that that's good I always
say to people don't tell them what
you're going to do just show them what
you did yeah because everyone can talk
oh I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this
and then all that's gonna happen is all
your friends and family are just gonna
be like yeah whatever but when you
actually show them and say we made 10
grand last month yeah well we've just
secured the keys to a new lease option
or we've just got a block of flats and
then it's like oh okay and then once
they've seen it then they start
supporting you a little bit more the
support's always been there like the
amount of times like my mum's had the
kids and the friends I've had the kids
like yeah if it was if it wasn't for
your mum and friend yeah talk to me
about the mindset that's needed in order
to succeed in this business it was the
mindset of it's only going to fail if
you don't put in practice what you learn
yeah and because we've watched videos
and everything that people like even the
bad reviews and stuff and not the first
thing I came away from like reading the
bad ones was they only failed because
they didn't
do what they learn yeah and also most of
the bad most of the bad comments online
or whatever are not from people who've
actually no they're not part of it
they've just watched a YouTube video or
maybe attended a one pound course yeah
but you know you guys are part of the
academy you know what the academy yeah
what the academy members are like like
everybody's winning and the environment
I think is really important as well
being around other people that are
winning and that are positive you know
every Monday you guys have been on the
Mastermind
um yeah you've been coming to the
dinners really immersing yourself and
it's hard to fail when you've got when
everybody around you is winning because
you're kind of the makeup of the people
around you I believe yeah well it's like
say the mentor it's not just about that
so because you meet like all the other
Academy members and that type of thing
the amount of times I'd like I'll just
phone one of them out and just they're
just a normal talk but they're doing the
same thing yeah so it's like like you
said it's surrounding a bit surrounding
yourself with yeah the right people 100
100 what what's it been like working
with me then for
what's it been like what's the
experience been like it's been really
good obviously the knowledge that we've
gained that's Second To None anyway
um with the Academy of the South the
network they bring
um that's I would say that's the biggest
thing for me
um because there's not really anyone
down by us that's that thing yeah
Network your network is your net worth
definitely if you could summarize top
tips of everything you've learned about
property about business what top tips
would you share mine firstly would be
not to kind of give in too soon like
obviously you've seen with us it was
just no no and constantly bashing your
head against the wall but if you keep
persevering it you will make a
breakthrough was there a moment when you
realized
this has changed our lives I would say
the second one second HMO because the
first one kit is kind of like all right
we've done it was it lucky was it luck
yeah and then you've done it again and
I've done it again and then it's kind of
just like all right yeah this is gonna
work what do you reckon along was there
a moment when you thought when did your
skepticism go away when did you kind of
you know a disbelief in the whole
process when did that just disappear it
was probably when we got the first set
of keys that I was like okay we can do
it but then it was probably when we got
the keys for Truro for the sa Flats
um yeah and the income that it was going
to bring in and I was like hey this is
really real now and it's everything's
going to change yeah yeah amazing and if
people want to get in touch with you you
know to brainstorm to do business or if
any landlords want to collaborate what
is the best way to get in touch with you
guys so for the rent to rent side it's
L&L housing limited on Instagram
um but then we also have a management
company for like holiday that's in down
in Cornwall which is Cornish Property
Management well thank you so much for
coming down and you know congrats on
what you've done you guys are absolute
winners you've smashed out the park you
know hopefully you'll be able to inspire
a lot of people from what you've done so
massive well done guys thanks for having
us thank you
[Music]